I never thought I'd see a good movie
with a CGI bear going to prison but here
we are
hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tara Jessa and today I went
and saw and thoroughly enjoyed
Paddington - how does a bit how is a
movie about a CGI bear so good how is a
movie about an animal that doesn't even
exist
so fawful with characters that are super
thoughtful super great super caring
lovely they teach you lessons how how
this isn't a video of me giving a
reaction or a review of Paddington dude
this is just me asking how for 10
minutes 10 minutes straight you ready
buckling I watched the first Paddington
movie a few days ago to gear up for this
one and I had heard from multiple people
that it was actually a really good film
and he was on Netflix and it's just one
that you kind of put off from watching
because how could it be good everyone
you're lying to me so I didn't watch it
until a few days back and he was so
delightful in the previews before the
film we got to other animal films like
CGI animal films we got Peter Rabbit and
one about Oh a talking dog who works for
like the CIA cuz of course and they
looked not good the talking dog one more
so looks terrible looks very cats and
dogs Eve and Peter Rabbit while it looks
like it is well made and well done it
just seems like I could be wrong has to
come out yet I haven't seen it but it
seems like the acting and the characters
especially are pretty shallow and like
there's not much there and you're
watching it because it's bunnies it's
like the vibe I get from it hopefully
I'm wrong but for animal movies like
this I feel like usually that's the case
usually you get some characters that
don't really matter
cuz the true stars paddington and then
padding to do silly things like Falls
and trips this is not that at all it's
so sweet and you learn tons of lessons
and the characters are so complex and
they change and it's just how is it what
what now I know this was a book series
before the films ever were even thought
about happening and I never was able to
read them but I know a lot of people
grew up with these books and so that's a
really cool thing to see something that
you grew up with on the big screen so
that's really fun that brings in a lot
of people to watch it but but people
that I wouldn't have even imagined would
like Paddington the bear have been like
oh yeah you didn't see Paddington it's
great what this might be the best sequel
I've seen in a very long time honestly
it was so sweet I cried at the end like
openly weeping because some CGI bears
were living their dreams I am going to
explain kind of what happens in the film
so spoilers but there's not like any
surprises it's just the story of
Paddington - the story is about
Paddington a talking bear who is living
in London and he wants to get his aunt
who is not living in London living back
home where he's from Peru I believe and
he wants to get her a birthday present
because he's the only living relative
she has and the whole story is about
getting this pop-up book of London and
raising money for it it's an old vintage
pop-up book and it's a thousand pounds
along the way you meet the character
that Hugh Grant plays and by the way not
a huge Hugh Grant fan myself he doesn't
do it for me he's not as endearing as I
think a lot of people find him for me
personally this was definitely his best
role I love doing this he got to play a
bunch of different characters because he
played an actor in the film and that's
always fun to see you and if there's a
great musical number at the end where
he's written I did so good but Hugh
Grant's character wants the pop-up book
because it's actually a treasure map to
find his grandfather's foes treasure
I know there's a lot happening in
Paddington - Wow so Hugh Grant steals
the book and Paddington is blamed for it
and Paddington goes to jail I never
thought I'd see a good movie with a CGI
bear going to prison but here we are so
of course it's about getting
Paddington's name cleared and getting
the book back and getting the present
for his aunt and of course the family is
there from the first movie and they're
all incredible and their characters have
developed even more and I adore the mom
in this film the only other thing I know
her from is the shape of water and she
likes animals that's for sure okay I
didn't know her name Sally Hawkins she
is completely new to me I've only seen
her now in Paddington one two and the
shape of water and she might be the most
genuinely sweet actress I've ever seen
in my entire life her smile just makes
you feel like oh she cares about
whatever I'm going through even if it's
in the film I don't care she just cares
about me specifically and I couldn't
watch anything she's in if there's any
other films I should check her out in
let me know in the comments because I
love her I love the daughter who got
dumped and now she started up her own
journalism class at school and as a
printing press loved it
I love the Sun who wants to be a cool DJ
type guy but he really likes steam
trains my name is not j-dog it's
Jonathan brown and I like steam trains
yes and the dad is so wonderful in both
films a little predictable and that he's
like the tight stiff dick up his butt
father figure but who loosens up when we
really need him to come through and a
little predictable in that but he plays
it so well and it's really endearing and
wonderful so they're all just like built
up really well and then another
character that you get again is the
security guard who is really in two men
cross dress as women
like yeah alright the jail seems really
stuck with me in a wonderful way I loved
the Paddington brightens up wherever
he's at while causing a mess and causing
havoc he also just changes everything
for the good and he's got these few
phrases that he goes over over and over
and over again that his aunt has taught
him and it's really sweet
they're simple like find the good in
people and and things like that and it's
just it's so simple but so well done and
it works incredibly well so in the jail
he's trying to find the good in people
and he accidentally puts a red sock in
all of the laundry it turns all of the
inmates
I also costumes their you know their
shirt and pants they turns them pink and
then teaches them how to make marmalade
sandwiches and just I mean turns it into
Mary Poppins pink marmalade cafe and
it's really sweet not realistic but very
cute maybe in Britain I imagine
everything there's just so sweet kind
delicious a great quote what's in the
gram of a family who says actors are
some of the most devious people on the
planet loved that I wrote down that it's
kind of Wes Anderson II in the colors
and they've also got a few moments where
they'll show a building and then they'll
open it up and you see what's happening
in every room and that really reminded
me of Wes Anderson and look at me
talking about a certain director like I
know things about Phil BAM yes good oh
man I've grown like I said at the end I
won't give away the very ending but I
was just weeping in the theater just
weeping about these bears living their
dreams a really sad thing to me although
I saw it at 11:30 a.m. on a Friday
morning there were only two other people
it started off with one somebody
scurried in like halfway through so no
one was there and then also the previews
were crap they were garbage they looked
all of them looked terrible
and it's not just because they were for
a younger crowd
they just didn't look good and so it was
I started off just being like oh no this
is not gonna be good and it was so good
I really wanted to see proud Mary and I
was like ah God Paddington it was
amazing and I would recommend it to
every single person I was going to watch
proud Mary as well for next week because
I'm gonna go to Hawaii oh I'm so excited
it's currently snowing outside of my
window in Chicago so I'm very excited
but I wasn't able to make it so there
will be no Tamra's Tamra just saw
there's so many shows with my name in it
too
two whole shows there won't be a Tamra
Jessa next week but I will see you the
week after
there will be Tamra's never seen though
Austin Powers so check that out and I'll
see you all very soon
[Music]